you come from a family of attorneys of
law oh yes yeah and so you were the
creative one I know you said your
brother directed and I know yeah they
did but I was the first one and it was
not an accident it's by design my father
wanted one artist in the family and
that's why it's so uncanny I was trained
in music classical dancing I mean boys
don't dance very rarely they do but it's
not considered to be the best thing to
do so I I downs I sang then I went then
I did a bit of karate and martial arts
of the South Indian form so I played the
veena which is a string instrument for a
while so my family and crazed me to do
all that your advice to other parents
what would you tell them about if one
child seems to be the creative one but
they have hopes to have them as a doctor
or a lawyer pharmacist that's very cruel
that's bonsai tree here making a huge
dream putting it into the glass cage
cage that is limited only by your
thinking it's unfair so I say that they
asked me how would you like my daughter
is into acting and it's her choice she
trained in music in America in music
institute that's what you wanted to do
probably she came back and she didn't do
music she did music for one of my phones
and then suddenly became an actress it's
a choice and she has found herself
hopefully she also does music and I
think I should be an agent of argument
adrene's not I mean I be it's all my
life
you